Este es un momento histórico que
redibuja el mapa de la seguridad en
Europa al unirse a la otan Finlandia
pasa página su política de no
alineamiento militar mi gente desde los
años 90 la primera consecuencia los
límites de la otan se desplazan hacia el
norte hasta la frontera con Rusia y se
extienden 1300 kilómetros la integración
de Finlandia amplía la Esfera de
influencia de la otan al Ártico una
región estratégica por sus recursos
naturales y su ubicación
americans creo que a los estadounidenses
franceses y británicos les interesa
desde un punto de vista geoestratégico
la defensa del norte de Europa resulta
mucho más fácil
otro interés para la alianza es el poder
militar finlandés la mayoría de los
hombres del país hacen el servicio
militar son una estadísticas oficiales
las tropas cuentan actualmente con
280.000 soldados y 900.000 reservistas
esto lo convierte en uno de los mayores
ejércitos de la alianza estas fuerzas ya
participan en ejercicios militares
conjuntos con la otan son expertos en
operaciones climáticas extremas
Finlandia posee una gran experiencia y
técnicas sutiles para los aliados
durante décadas todos los niveles de la
sociedad se han estado preparando para
la posibilidad de un conflicto con Rusia
helsinki almacena el equivalente a seis
meses de suministros de combustible y
muchos edificios tienen refugios
antiaéreos